>> From the library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
[ Silence ]
>> Kenneth Nyirady: I'd
like to welcome all of you
to the European Division.
My name is Kenneth Nyirady.
I am the specialist for Hungary.
Grant Harris, the head
of the Reading Room,
regrets that he can't be here
today to introduce the speaker.
Born in Vienna, Austria,
[laughter] Kurt Bednar graduated
from the University of Vienna
Faculty of Law in 1974.
He has found employment with
governments and chambers of commerce
as well as entrepreneurial positions
in fields such as databases,
data protection, and
company pensions.
He graduated from the University
of Vienna a second time in 2012
with a doctorate from the
Faculty of Philosophy Department
of History based on a
thesis entitled "Emigration
from Austria Hungary to the
U.S.A. between 1900 and 1930."
This work will appear in book
form by the end of this year.
He has published books on
computing and construction industry,
data protection laws,
and company pensions.
And two of his books are available
here at the Library of Congress.
And their titles are in German, and
I won't dare try to pronounce them.
He has written numerous articles
dealing with law and related fields.
He has published his first
book review last year.
He is also a member of the
scientific advisory board
for the House of Austrian History
to be established in Lower Austria,
and to be opened by the end of 2017.
The title of this presentation today
is "Frederic Courtland Penfield,
Last and Undervalued US Minister
to Habsburg Vienna in
Crisis, 1913 1917."
It is my honor to introduce
to you Dr. Kurt Bednar.
[ Applause ]
[ Silence ]
>> Kurt Bednar: Thank you very
much for coming and Mr. Nyirady
with the map of the
monarchy long gone.
We quickly changed to
the man of this hour,
Frederic Cortland Penfield.
When Woodrow Wilson, President
of the United States of America,
wrote a letter to Franz Joseph
the First, emperor of Austria,
dated July 29, 1913, he
announced the arrival
of Frederic Cortland Penfield
to reside near the government
of his majesty as ambassador
extraordinary and plenipotentiary.
He had chosen this distinguished
citizen as well informed
of the relative interests
of the two countries.
As a matter of fact, Penfield
had been Wilson's second choice.
His first choice, Egan, had
refused to accept the post in Vienna
since life in Vienna
would be quite expensive.
In fact, Penfield was chosen
because he was a Catholic,
and he had no idea
what he was up to.
As soon as Vienna learned of the
probable nomination of Penfield,
Austrian Ambassador Dumba
was asked to look around.
He had New York Consul
General Nuber inquire,
as Penfield at that
time lived in New York.
The information Vienna
received was pleasing enough.
According to Nuber's telegram,
Penfield, 58, was a journalist,
explorer, writer, of distinguished
appearance, and, due to studies
in Germany, mastering German.
His wife was also Catholic
and wealthy.
Some 30 million U.S.
dollars, which had resulted
in the richest contribution to
the latest Democratic ticket.
A footnote is in the German
speaking New York "Staats Zeitung"
at that time a relatively
high, a large number
of newspapers was published
in German of June 26,
speculated that as he was wealthy.
He ought to be able to become
the most radiant diplomatic
representative of the new U.S.
administration, which, of course,
pleased the Vienna court eager
for splendor and recognition.
In 1916 Penfield complained
to Wilbur Carr,
Director of the Consular
Service at that time,
that he paid 24,000 U.S. dollars
for his residence of 60 rooms,
among them a dining room
hosting up to 60 guests.
The American embassy in Vienna even
furnished Austria's Foreign Minister
Count Berchtold with some sort
of curriculum vitae of Penfield.
This one page document also
registered the awards showered upon
him by countries like England,
France, Turkey, and Serbia.
The official Dictionary of American
Biography described his public
character, "It has brought
him to London and Cairo
where he must have spent
the high time of his life,
as has his two books, 'Present
Day Egypt' and 'East of Suez,
written in the 16 years
between Cairo and Vienna,
deal with that oriental country."
Earlier he had already
earned his living by writing.
He spent his junior years in the
staff of a Hartford newspaper.
There are not many
sources on Mrs. Penfield,
but the few available
mark her as an open minded
and generous personality.
During her stay in Vienna she took
German lessons in Baden near Vienna.
Her teacher, Gustav Brown [assumed
spelling], Louisen Strasse 22,
was proud portrait
with this prominent
and obviously ambitious pupil.
When reading the thank you card
no problem one wonders how good a
teacher she picked, as he signed
as her "sprachlerer," if you look
at the last one, without
an h [laughter].
Back home Mrs. Penfield
excelled as a generous donator,
not only to the Pennsylvania
Historical Society.
Upon the death of her husband
in 1922, she received a letter
from Colonel House in which
the formerly trusted advisor
of Woodrow Wilson expected that
history will do him justice.
This history has failed to happen.
Among other authors, Rachel West,
in particular, accuses Penfield,
described as an ambassador
elsewhere, of several flaws.
First of all, Penfield
is conceited to a fault
and could strut sitting down.
But this is hearsay.
The source, Grew, who had
worked in Vienna before,
probably didn't like him.
In the end we will hear why.
Secondly, Penfield never lost
his fondness for boasting.
Finally, West deplores the
bad quality of his reports,
mocking topics like cholera
and the health of the emperor,
especially that he did not
foresee the coming disaster.
In truth, as we all know,
the war caught Penfield,
like most of other U.S.
representatives in Europe
and many other people, by surprise.
His first job now was to
support Americans getting
out of the country
if they so wished.
All together, it's estimated
that about 50,000 Americans
stranded in Europe in 1914.
In that era, passports were
the exception of the rule.
His staff had to identify Americans,
issue proper travel papers,
and provide sojourners with cash.
Obviously enough ships
were available
in Europe to return all Americans.
Several months into the
war, Penfield suffers
from a growing shortage
of personnel.
A young Austrian, age 25, with
the name Leo Threschel [phonetic]
from Mistelbach, north of
Vienna, was called to the colors.
He happened to be working for
Penfield as second gardener.
After the ambassador had
already lost seven servants
to the Austrian army, he contacted
Berchtold, the foreign minister,
stating, "I can't very
well live in Vienna
as an ambassador unless
allowed some servants."
Penfield also put in a good
word for his chief gardener,
Johann Prohaska [assumed
spelling], 35, his chief butler,
Ernst Weininger [assumed
spelling], 38, they're all mentioned
in this paper, and
the house servant,
Albert Urschinger [assumed
spelling], age 24.
Him he regarded as too tall
and fragile to make a soldier.
"And Threschel is so
nearly stone deaf
that I am sure he would
make a poor warrior.
He's, however, a good
worker in my glass houses,
and I wish the war ministry
would send him back."
Minister Berchtold
supported the desire.
As the U.S. kept a difficult
course of neutrality,
America was approached
by belligerents
to represent their interests
towards respective hosts.
Thus Penfield had to inspect
prisoner camps in Austria on behalf
of Italy, which had declared
war on Austria in May 1915.
On February 28, 1916, he did inspect
Katzenau, a site in a Linz suburb.
Frankly speaking, I
haven't had learned before
of this place before I
came across this document.
Typical Viennese would say.
Penfield was in the company of two
of his staff, Naval Attache Graham
and his private secretary,
Karl Daser [phonetic],
and the Baron Freitental
[phonetic] Austrian Ministry
of Foreign Affairs.
Katzenau, at that time only
sheltered civil prisoners,
enemy aliens, camp director Baron
Reiche [assumed spelling] was also
a civilian.
According to the report of March
14th, U.S. inspectors checked menus
and daily rations as
well as tasted the milk,
"sweet and of good quality" produced
by some 50 cows near the camp.
The whole food supply was
managed by a committee
of five selected among
the detainees.
Any inhabitant was free to
grab food somewhere else.
There was a canteen and private
Austrian shops on the ground.
But alcohol was restricted
to one liter of beer
and half a liter of wine per day.
What a restriction [laughter].
All together, the camp's capacity
was estimated up to 5,600 persons.
On the day of inspection
Katzenau had 4,300 inmates,
3,300 of which were Italians.
Sanitation and cleanliness
were observed
by medical [inaudible] named
Bertolini [assumed spelling],
obviously of Italian background.
The doctor testified
to the U.S. group
that no contagious diseases
had occurred recently.
Money was not allowed in Katzenau.
Instead of cash, which landed in
a depo, people received Lagergeld,
camp money, and that currency
worked everywhere in Katzenau,
but nowhere outside, thus keeping
inmates from trying to escape.
Overall, the report resumed
no serious complaints.
From the beginning of the conflict,
Penfield had sent voluminous reports
from his office in Vienna to
U.S. Secretary of State Lansing
and Colonel House in Washington
and New York, respectively.
On January 28, 1915, he sent a
report to Bryan when still Secretary
of State about the first
six months of the war.
Penfield's central observation was
a lack of impartial information
since authorities installed
censorship
and forbade foreign newspapers.
What is striking in
his, is his finding
of early war wariness
in the population.
Vienna itself was full of disabled
soldiers and fleeing civilians.
Quite importantly, Penfield
already seemed to have good context
with the court, as the new Foreign
Minister Czernin kept the American
informed about the good
health of the emperor.
His report referred to four American
military observers at the front,
two of whom, Major
Fort [assumed spelling]
and Captain McIntyre [assumed
spelling] narrowly escaped
from Belgrade when it was
taken over by the Serbs again,
a third being in Galicia, which is
up, up north, and the fourth active
in Pula, which is the,
was the Austrian naval
center in the Adriatic.
The first war loan in
Austrian raised good money,
if at an interest rate
of five percent; however,
at international markets Austria
would have to pay interest
up to ten percent, sorry,
five three quarter and up
to ten percent they would
have paid on the free market.
Penfield deplored the lack of
social life in the Austrian capital,
although the well noticed character
of the Viennese coffee house
as yet could be upheld.
People abhorred French and English,
and Americans had a hard time
to explain that they are
different from perfidious albion.
The city seemed, this is quote
from, "The city seemed to be able
to keep normal supply
with food, however.
Private cars had disappeared also
because tires could
not be found anywhere."
In the document in the Vienna
state archive you can find several
requests from Penfield
for tire and for gasoline.
And sometimes he got some,
but he had a hard time.
Penfield thought most Americans
had left Austria, with just 200
and 250 persons staying by their
own choice or for business,
sojourning in Tyrol or
studying theology in Innsbruck.
I didn't find out who it was.
A truly comprehensive document
followed by a report titled,
"Austria Hungary After a Year
of War" dated July 29, 1915.
What is remarkable is
a receiver of this.
The envelope was addressed to Mrs.
Richard Meyers in Philadelphia
who was Mrs. Penfield's
favorite niece.
The report had several sections.
Italy's entrance into the
war, the estimated number
of soldiers fighting for Austria
Hungary, human care of prisoners,
evidences of racial differences of
opinion, controlling the consumption
of staple foods, expedience for
raising war necessaries, warning,
waning supplies of cotton and
rubber, and war's crushing costs.
Meanwhile, Lansing
had replaced Bryan
and obviously introduced
his own idea of reporting.
Intervals shortened, different
structure, compulsory.
Papers include Penfield's summations
dated November 11, November 25,
December 9, all in
1915, to be followed
by a document of January
2nd of 1916.
The last report in the files of the
Pennsylvania Historical Society,
addressed, "My dear Mr.
Secretary," but not printed,
not printed in the Lansing papers.
It completely covered
the Ancona affair
and displayed the functionary aware
of the practice of
Austrian bureaucracy.
I'm sure you're, if you're
not aware, Ancona was the ship
that was torpedoed by
an Austrian submarine.
It was actually a German
submarine, but it was under the,
under the Austrian war flag.
On November 19, 1915, Penfield
questioned the new foreign minister
Burian, who insisted that Austria
had a right to sink enemy ships
but also promised to inquire
internally for more effects.
After five days, November 25th,
the American already suspecting
official procrastination,
asked again to see Burian.
When Penfield referred to his
instructions regarding promptness,
Burian again asked
for a few more days.
When Penfield wanted
assurance that it was, indeed,
an Austrian submarine that sank
the Ancona, Burian weakly admitted
that this, in a wake manner,
continuing that the war could be
over would not America ship
munitions to the allies.
Penfield, who set a sort of
ultimatum on December 1st,
in the meantime had received a
note of protest from Washington
to deliver to the foreign
ministry in Vienna.
At the next meeting, December 9, he
handed over the first protest note.
Around Christmas of 1915 it looked
like severance of the relations
between both states, and
Penfield even issued a call
to all U.S. diplomats
in the monarchy
to get prepared for departure.
Penfield, however, stayed for
another year and continued
with his reports from Vienna.
These came in two versions.
Shorter, both by length
and by interval to Lansing,
whereas comprehensive half year
summations were addressed mainly
to Colonel House with whom he
developed a warmer relationship.
His first memo in the
collection of House papers
at Yale was dated January 28, 1916.
It carried the title, "Austria
Hungary After 18 Months of War,"
and would be succeeded by two
war memos of the same structure
and description covering two
years of war, dated July 28, 1916,
and 30 months of war,
dated January 28, 1917.
Subsequently, reports from
Vienna were not possible,
as the relations were broken up.
Stovall, the U.S. Legation in Berne,
continued with memos
about the monarchy.
Penfield's first reports
printed in the federal records
of foreign relations of the U.S.,
called FRUS, dated November 4, 1915,
pursuant to your request
for frequent confidential
and personal letters, contained one
significant piece of information,
one very material piece
of information, indeed.
Vienna was not going to
nominate a successor of Dumba,
who had been expelled, all too soon,
so long as private communication
with Vienna was impossible
to send an ambassador
to the Washington would
be worse than useless.
This topic repeated itself in the
later message of June 15, 1916,
when Penfield assumed this
government will take no action
in that direction until
the war is over.
Three times Wilson himself reacted
to the reports shown by Lansing,
but his comments probably
reached Lansing only.
On July 27, 1916, on the
report dated July 3, 1916,
Wilson finally spent praise
on his ambassador in Vienna.
"He always says something that
is useful to keep in mind."
The late January 1916, memo from
Vienna, not fit to print in FRUS
to House, commenced
with the conclusion
that even 18 months could
not starve the monarchy,
thus contradicting earlier
hints of war wariness.
Food seemed to be distributed
effectively,
although people did suffer
from potato and meat shortage.
Two days a week meat was
not allowed to be sold,
and butter has become
a luxury of the rich.
Outlook to future harvests
and transports
from Romania and Hungary looked dim.
Women and children, but also Russian
and Serbian prisoners
of war, had to help out.
The 24 page memo closed with
a short paragraph titled,
"Good health of the emperor."
Foreign minister Burian
had just assured Penfield
that the majesty was never
better in his 86th year.
Franz Joseph still began his
work at 4:00 in the morning
and took the keenest interest
in every phase of the campaign.
Further reports from Vienna
contained even more pages.
July 28, 1916, two years of
war, consisted of 34 pages.
January 28, 1917, and of 30
months of war, even of 44 pages.
With Penfield leaving
town in April 1917,
he strangely disappeared
into oblivion.
The inquiry, the group set up
by Colonel House upon request
by President Wilson,
set up to prepare
for a peace conference did
not bother to interview him.
On August 18, 1917, Penfield
claimed to receive confidential
and extremely reliable
information from Vienna.
In a reply of August 28, 1917,
Colonel House, who was responsible
for the inquiring, thanked earlier,
for earlier letters
Penfield had written to him.
House considered that the ex
ambassador had said about Austria,
what the ex ambassador had said
about Austria exceedingly
interesting and referred
to a meeting with Lansing, who
would have passed the message
on to the President himself, to
whom you have given the benefit
of your views, maybe, maybe
they got together in September,
when the Houses would have been
running up for a day from New York.
In the meantime, the
Penfields had settled
down in Mamaroneck
in upstate New York.
But one can read between
the lines, he was gone.
Nevertheless, between the two men,
the under valued writer turned
into diplomat and the
eventual alter ego
of the President himself must have
existed out of a kind of friendship.
In the House papers collection
at Yale, one may find corresponds
from February 13 until fall of 1917.
It begins with a performance
of Seraglio [assumed spelling]
at the Metropolitan Opera.
Penfield, living on Fifth
Avenue, invites House,
35th Street, for dinner at 7:00.
The invitation closes with a remark
that he promises not to appear
in the attitude of a candidate
for a place in the cabinet.
Was Penfield under discussion
to become a minister?
Certainly House would
have been the man
to influence the newly elected
Woodrow Wilson, re elected,
when forming his first
cabinet, no elector.
Sorry. On July 23, 1913,
Penfield thanked House
for his good wishes upon his
appointment, formally on July 28,
to the ambassadorship in Vienna.
Which, so he claimed, "It is
the position I most coveted."
Admitting that it might have helped
that the ambassadorial
couple was Catholic.
He was received by Franz Joseph
only in September because he was,
Penfield was vacationing in Carlsbad
in the summer, and Franz Joseph,
as usual, was in Bad
Ischl, of course.
Not before January 18, 1915, do
we meet another correspondence,
House announces yet another trip
to Europe, sailing on the Lusitania
on January the 13th, which was
four months before it sank,
was torpedoed, which by
now has become a war area.
House asks for information from
Vienna sent to his first stop,
London, as it might become opportune
for him to travel to Vienna.
Penfield obviously had no
idea of House's mission,
replies on February 11,
actually warmly commending Vienna
as the most normal yet tensest
of all the war capitals.
It houses 50,000 wounded soldiers,
150,000 refugees from Galicia,
and 1000 Russian prisoners, but the
kaiserstadt is comfortable and safe.
As we know, House never made it to
Vienna, but on March 20 in a note
from the U.S. Embassy in Berlin,
House invites Penfield to come
over to him since he refers
to important reasons not to go
to Vienna, and on the other hand,
he welcomes Penfield's advice.
Another letter of House
to Vienna, March 9 or 10,
with news from Washington about
another reshuffle in diplomacy
as Morgenthau leaves Constantinople
to be replaced by a
man called Elkus.
Penfield reacts with
a letter of April 13,
commenting on the situation
in Constantinople and hoping
for a stopover of Elkus in Vienna
on his way to Constantinople.
Finally, he reclaims that our
efforts and labors are recognized
and appreciated not
only there but also
by governments he's representing
in Vienna due to the war.
Thus, thus far, we seem to
have made not one mistake
to steer a great embassy
in this exacting capital
where our neutrality is often
doubted is a task admitting
of no neglect.
On April 15, 1916, Penfield
uttered a confidential
and surprising request
to switch to Paris.
If the ambassador there,
Sharp, retired.
House must have given him this idea,
according to his word
to this writing.
Did he build up his story
in the letter of April 13?
It took house until May 11 to answer
both April messages from Vienna.
Wilson and Lansing seemed not
to appreciate a direct switch
from one belligerent to another.
Next, June 5th.
On the last page of an unusually
long letter did Penfield recall the
intended switch to Paris and
admits [inaudible] is perfect,
and it was my idea all the time.
Before Penfield wrote
about mediation.
"Our President may not
be the best mediator.
Austria prefers the King of Spain.
And if that does not work,
him together with Wilson.
Even the Pope wouldn't
do, as people here prefer
as peacemaker a potentate whose
influence is more than spiritual."
Austria does not feel
comfortable with Wilson's ideas,
especially the right of
every race to govern itself,
which might conflict
with the interest
of a monarch ruling Austrians,
Hungarians, Bohemians,
Slavs, Croats, and other races.
Penfield's next letter
of September 19 deals
with the financial contribution
to the election campaign,
but you need make no
accounting of it.
Only one day later, one may find
yet another three page message
to the colonel covering Penfield's
experience with the new ambassador
to Constantinople, Elkus, who
did accept his invitation to stop
over in Vienna on his way
to the Ottoman capital,
joyful as he was an event dragging
ten people and 50 trunks with him,
joining his host at the Vienna
Opera as well as at a chat
with Austrian's Foreign
Minister Burian.
On the other hand, against his
advice, Elkus gave interviews both
in Vienna and Budapest, Budapest.
His campaign contribution is
acknowledged by House in his letter
of October 25, together with a
promise that it will not appear
until the final summary in November.
Then the election.
Penfield, on November 22, indulges
in schadenfreude that all papers
in this monarchy for two days
paraded the news of the election
of Mr. Hughes, and certain important
Vienna journals let loose afresh
their floodgates of Wilson abuse.
Meanwhile, the emperor has
passed away, and Penfield claims
to have received probably his last
picture taken shortly before his
death and presented to him with
an affectionate inscription.
Penfield claims not only the
new kaiser and his wife Zita
as close friends of himself
and Mrs. Penfield but also
and specially ex minister Berchtold.
"Perhaps my closest
friend here who now works
in the staff of the new emperor."
In another correspondence,
we meet the influential
Chicago industrialist Crane.
Crane was very important.
He brought, he brought Masaryk
and Wilson together,
was very influential.
On April 26, 1916, he answers
Charles Crane on behalf
of Alice Masaryk for whom
he has intervened, April 22.
Penfield even interviewed with
Foreign Minister Burian on behalf
of her and received the
following information.
"She's being held here on
a charge of high treason."
Half a year later, Crane contributes
1,000 U.S. dollars for Penfield
to spend on her comfort and show her
courtesies or see that they occur
without embarrassing
Penfield officially.
Quite a job.
Penfield was quite talkative
towards Maurice Bunsen,
whom he was acquainted
with from the time
when Bunsen represented
India at the Viennese court.
But, of course, since Austria
and England were at war now,
this letter was sent to London.
Penfield deplored the activities
of one British journalist
with the name Aubrey Stanhope,
who wrote for Vienna's
Neue Freie Presse.
But Mr. Ambassador, Mr.
Penfield, was an effective
and efficient letter worker,
befriended with the owner and editor
of the paper and even received his
apologies when Stanhope described
in an article Lansing as a lawyer
of mediocre abilities and Wilson
as a weak doctrinaire
of Scotch decent.
Finally, when Stanhope
planned to write about the idea
that Wilson deliberated the entry
of the U.S. into the war because,
in that case, the election
would be cancelled
and his term automatically
prolonged, Penfield succeeded
in banning this man from
further publishing in this paper.
There is still more Penfield
correspondence available.
One recipient is journalist
friend Henry Watterson at the
"Courier Journal" in
Louisville, Kentucky.
On March 24, 1916,
obviously [inaudible] please
for the postcards.
Penfield is delighted how well
his work seems to be regarded
in this monarchy never
too friendly with America.
There are also vacation
postcards of October 3, 1915,
with a war photograph on the back
side, "Unsere Truppen im Felde"
and of October 22, 1914, with a
pretty view of Traunsee, Gmunden,
Schloss Ort in lovely Salzkammergut.
Further down, probably,
or further up.
Sorry. There it is.
You might, some might recognize it.
Both stamped in Vienna, one
respectively nine days later.
The card of 1914 must
have been further delayed
because of two factors.
It was directed via Italy
and it carries the
censorship stamp "uberpruft."
Another friend corresponding
with Penfield is John Bassett
Moore, also Republican.
The file in the Library of
Congress Moore papers commences
with a would be the
best moment right now,
I would like to thank the
Library of Congress for, for the,
for this service they provide.
It's astonishing, and
it's really unbelievable.
European Reading Room,
past manuscript division,
really everybody.
Thank you.
The file in the Library
of Congress commences
with a Penfield letter
of January 4, 1915.
Penfield admits of homesickness,
lack of men and women of our class,
not enough appreciation and
encouragement from the department.
"War broke into violence that might
have swept novices from their feet,
but we rose to the occasion.
A lot of expenses due to
circumstances of the war,
and for 17 months I have not
been absent from my post."
Penfield is naturally getting little
of the poetry of diplomatic life,
and as we know from other occasions,
from other writing occasions,
I have never had a press clock.
On December 2nd he reiterates
the public, publicity stigma.
"At times I fear I have
been too conservative
in not encouraging publicity.
It was my promise to Wilson
not to be much in the papers.
If I have failed at all, it is in
permitting the Stars and Stripes
to be taken down over the
American bar at the Bristol Hotel
and the Bulgarian flag
substituted there for it."
A convent in a Vienna
suburb shelters a kind
of farm I couldn't find out
which one it was a cow and hens
on behalf of the embassy.
Of course, on Thanksgiving three
or four of them lost their being
for a dinner at the embassy
with music afterwards.
Where else may one find anything
about America's last ambassador
to the ailing court of Vienna?
One U.S. dissertation deals
with American embassies
in belligerent Europe.
Bell, the author, 1983,
University of Iowa.
It has a prominent
supervisor, Lawrence Gelfend,
author of the only
book on the inquiry.
The group of experts Wilson in the
early '17 asked House to gather
in preparation for the
upcoming peace conference.
Chapter 9 of this dissertation has
the title "Frederic C. Penfield
and the Vienna Embassy, 1914
to 1918," which is, in itself,
questionable, as relations
were terminated in 1917.
And unfortunately, not the only bug.
What Bell describes as the
most blatant reporting error
that there will be fewer
small governments in Europe
when the war is over, actually
results from his earlier comments
which were quite common
thoughts at that time.
That Austria, on a federalist
basis, would integrate most
of the small Balkan states.
To be true, the ambassador
was less sensitive
to dissensions among the
nationalities which made
up the Habsburg domain,
but he noticed intensified
conflicts among the minorities.
What he did neither noticed nor
report was any threat to breaking
up because of war generated
racial tensions.
On top of all, Bell would
have liked Penfield to meet
with dissident ethnic
leaders in Austria.
Vienna would have been delighted
to be offered such an opportunity
to take revenge for
Dumba's expulsion.
The term ended in a rift.
Penfield seemed to have
assured Czernin of,
Austria's foreign secretary,
of Tarnowski's reception,
that was the designated
new ambassador,
Tarnowski's reception by Wilson.
He never was received by Wilson.
When this idea was turned
down and Penfield recalled,
he had only disconnected the two
moves but spoke openly, not only,
to the local press,
thus saving his face.
With him, embassy and
cultural staff with many pieces
of heavy luggage, left
town and country.
A further approved list of 48
American citizens with 70 items
of luggage went on the
embassy's official train,
among them a private couple
named Stonborough, here listed.
Of course, Margaret Stonborough is
the sister of Ludwig Wittgenstein.
With two sons and servants, as
well as one group of Red Cross
and another of YMCA people.
At that moment, the U.S.
entertained a network of diplomats
in eight locations scattered
over the dual monarchy.
Consulate in Budapest, but also a
consulate in Carlsbad, for example.
In a handwritten note to
Czernin dated April 8, 1917,
the U.S. embassy, represented by
Grew, acknowledged the receipt
of the Austrian note of the same day
by which relations broke
up and of the passports.
The U.S. exodus from Vienna was
painted in a quite different light
by a journalist, Schreiner
[assumed spelling],
of the "Dearborn Independent."
First, Penfield [inaudible]
because of Tarnowski's mishap,
then he orchestrated his
departure as a simple recall,
and finally he avenged
himself on Grew
by having him pick up the passports.
According to Schreiner,
the Department of State
by then only trusted two persons
in the Vienna staff,
Stuart and Bingham.
On the other hand, it was a
recent [inaudible] of my research,
just for one week, a
special envoy took launch
in Vienna whose single duty might
have been to wrap up things quickly,
at least luring Drasal [assumed
spelling], he's also in this list,
just for one single week.
He was later to play an important
role in Germany and Berlin.
Rumors had it that
Grew was connected
to the pro ally Morgan clan and
destined to replace Penfield.
It cannot come as a surprise, then,
that Grew characterized
Penfield as described by West.
Is it possible that
Penfield's meager refuse derived
from his political stigmatization?
He was considered the
political appointee,
but even then he may have
been doing a good job.
Did it just have bad luck being
sent to dead end street Vienna?
The monarchy played a small role in
the conflict right at the beginning
and at the end when it collapsed.
Remarkable was a lack of reports on
national disputes in the monarchy.
Overall, Mr. Penfield
must be evaluated at least
above average of America's envoys.
His widespread correspondence
proves diplomatic abilities,
financial generosity, and fine,
almost British humor
in addressing issues.
What else can one expect?
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Kenneth Nyirady: Okay.
We have time for questions.
>> I have a question
about the postcard
that had the word uber something
the word censored on it.
>> Kurt Bednar: Uberpruft.
>> Uberpruft.
>> Kurt Bednar: Checked.
>> How extensive was the censorship
bureaucracy of the Austrians,
or was this just a wartime
measure that they had?
>> Kurt Bednar: Basically
a wartime measure.
As soon as the war started they one
thing that this mostly overseen is
that the Austrian parliament was
not sitting when the war started,
but it was not because
of censorship or anything
but because the parliament,
as Mark Twain has reported
from Vienna some years ago,
was a tumultuous arena,
so the emperor just closed it
down in March 1914
because it didn't work.
But it was not, nothing else.
But I didn't recall the parliament
for the operating of the war.
It's another issue.
But no, the, it was, it was
basically a war measure.
>> Okay. Thank you.
>> Kurt Bednar: Harsh, but.
>> Kenneth Nyirady:
Any other questions?
>> I have a question.
I didn't hear very much
about the communication
of Vienna's government[inaudible]
to the Kaiser [inaudible] you know,
did the U.S. perceive
what was going on?
Is there documentation on that or,
I mean, is there correspondence
between different diplomats
or is this not available?
>> Kurt Bednar: Well, Penfield was
not very popular in Washington,
wasn't trusted by Lansing too much.
They did have a difficult
relationship,
so whenever there was something
going on between Washington
and Vienna, they tried to talk
to the Austrian representatives
in Washington.
Mr. Tredennick [assumed spelling],
he was an Austrian representative
at that time when Dumba
was expulsed.
He had a good relationship
with Lansing,
so Lansing mostly turned
to Tredennick.
And the Americans also
liked Tarnowski.
But when Tarnowski came
in the spring of '17,
the Germans started the
unlimited submarine campaign,
and so there was no way they would,
Wilson would receive
Tarnowski anymore.
There was one moment when Penfield
could have risen to some importance
in the, in the history of the war
when the Americans tried desperately
to separate Austria from
Germany and there were, I think,
four secret meetings
between Penfield
and Foreign Secretary Czernin.
But in the longer version of the
paper I had it in more detail.
But Penfield was not well informed
by Washington why, what was the goal
of the meeting, and
Czernin suspected
that the Americans were abused
by the British and the French
for a proposal to come to separate
peace, but it, that was not true
because it was a genuine American
initiative and not supported by,
supported but not initiated by
the real enemies of Austria.
I mean, there was no, there was
no real war between the U.S.
and Austria Hungary,
as you might be aware.
Just in the end, there were
a couple of shots were fired
on the western front
when the Americans,
when the Germans asked the
Austrians to move some troops
from the southern and eastern
front to the western front.
In a document I found in the
state archive in Vienna, Czernin,
the Austrian foreign secretary
muttered in this paper that we are,
what we are doing with America
is a paper war, papierkrieg.
>> Kenneth Nyirady:
Any other questions?
>> Yes. How did you get interested
in this particular matter,
or are you covering more
thoroughly the relationships
between this country and the empire?
>> Kurt Bednar: Not
anymore, not anymore.
I must my wife is American.
She's from Minnesota.
And that, what, I chose the topic
of emigration in the first place
in dealing with the
emigration thing, then it more
or less gradually, I passed on the
interests of the first world war
because what was so astounding
is, if you go, for example,
we went to the office in town
hall in New Ulm, Minnesota,
to check immigration papers.
And you saw all kinds of people
from Bohemia, Upper Austria,
Lower Austria, but
there wasn't Austria
as such when the people came in.
So it makes you think.
I'm sure you're aware of the
refugee crisis in Europe right now.
So how do we treat
those people that come?
How were the Austrians
treated 100 years ago
when they came to Ellis Island?
And all, so it circled all around
in the end to what I'm doing now,
the relationship between the
U.S. and Austria Hungary.
>> I wish you would have another
talk on that whole immigration thing
at that time, and, you know
>> Kurt Bednar: Maybe.
Yeah.
>> like you said, until 1930,
because I have met so many people
from all of the various countries.
And invariably, you know, where
your parents are from doesn't come
up in a discussion about Austria
Hungary, but it just comes
up like what is your background.
Oh, we were Austrian Hungarian.
Well, really Czech, but
we were [inaudible],
and then somebody else would say.
Oh, I went to the dedication of
the Hungarian chapel last year,
and I met an old Franciscan coming
down the driveway, and I said,
"Were you at the dedication?
Are you Hungarian?"
Oh, no. I'm Slovakian,
but we've all [inaudible].
>> Kurt Bednar: Yeah,
sure [laughter].
>> That's what he said.
He said we all knew Hungarians.
So it was very impressive.
So it's interesting to me how these
people did identify themselves
as Austria Hungary, even though we
hear about all of the conflicts.
>> Kurt Bednar: Yeah, they
happened in the monarchy.
Supposedly some happened
in the States as well.
That's why the government wanted
the, didn't like the [inaudible],
they didn't like these
[inaudible], as you know.
And in the end, the first
[inaudible] the bridge
between migration and
the current topic is
because actually the first world
war helped to cover up this problem
because there were, as you know,
Russians chose, I don't know,
Germans, Irish in America.
And the war covered everything up.
Sorry. Somehow, yeah.
And my question was at the end
of my thesis was I hope
we don't need another war
to solve this problem.
>> Yes. That's a good one.
>> Kurt Bednar: Not a good one.
No.
>> A good point.
>> I confess I'm not a
scholar or an academic.
I'm just an ordinary American and
don't often have a chance to speak
to an Austrian historian.
So I hope you allow this question,
which is a little broader
than the topic.
You spoke of the friendship of
Ambassador Penfield and his wife
with the new emperor Karl
and the Empress Zita.
At St. Mary's Church in
Chinatown here in DC is a shrine
to the Emperor Charles,
who was beatified
by Pope John Paul years ago.
>> Kurt Bednar: That's right.
Yes.
>> I wonder how that
event, that beatification,
was looked on in Austria,
and I also ask your opinion.
I wonder whether or not you
consider the Emperor Karl
to have been an admirable figure.
>> Kurt Bednar: [Laughter]
how long do you [laughter].
Well, he was an unhappy
figure, wasn't he?
I mean, unhappy, very unhappy.
He could have achieved so much, and
he achieved practically nothing.
So he was not well prepared
enough to take over.
He was, he was good will, had good
will, and he wanted peace and stuff
like that, but how he tried to make
it was not professional, probably.
It's difficult to answer
this question.
I don't know if beatification
is a good idea, anyway.
I've been raised as a Catholic, but
I left the church a long time ago,
so it's no use to talk about
Catholic things like that.
But where is this church?
I would like to go there.
Where is it, and?
>> It's at the corner of 5th and H
>> Kurt Bednar: Oh, yeah.
>> which is about halfway between
the Capitol and the White House.
It's next to the General
Accounting Office,
which covers that whole
block with the corner.
>> Kurt Bednar: Fifth
and H. I'll go there.
I'll go there.
>> It's a German language, was
founded as a German language church.
>> Kurt Bednar: Okay.
>> Thank you.
>> Kurt Bednar: Thank you.
>> Kenneth Nyirady:
Any other questions?
>> I think I have a comment to
make related to your comment,
and that is in the United States
when people come from abroad,
the question often
is, are you a Czech?
Are you a Serb?
Are you a whatever?
So I came to the U.S. when I was 16,
and I did consider myself Yugoslav.
So when I arrived here, I
would say I'm from Yugoslavia.
And the next question was
always, well, are you a Serb?
Are you a [laughter].
And so I think this is
something that is a legacy
of immigration to the United States.
People come here because, perhaps,
earlier generations have come
because of wars, because
they, you know,
did not agree with
some other nationality.
But people in Europe may
have a different take
on who they are in general.
Just a comment.
>> Kurt Bednar: Okay.
>> Than people here.
Than people here, yes.
>> Kurt Bednar: Okay.
>> Kenneth Nyirady:
Any other questions?
Well, I'd like to thank the
speaker for a wonderful,
very interesting and
enlightening talk.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.